I didn't tell you any of the data to
support this but I want to give you this
as a something to think about this is
not a model this is a fact that the way
the nervous system is wired up to muscle
is much more complicated at birth than
it is two weeks later and that is you
have something that's akin to an all-too
all connectivity where each neuron
diverges to make synapses on many if not
all the muscle fibers and each muscle
fiber receives convergent input from
many axons and you go 2 weeks later and
then you have this hyper simple wiring
diagram and I you just have to take my
word for because I didn't show you the
data to support this but this is the way
it is I've spent 30 years studying this
phenomenon and this is the adult pattern
and it stays this way without change
until an animal is very old it means
that when the wiring diagram is young in
a mammal there are all sorts of
possibilities and then through the magic
of development choices are made and a
very small subset of what Italy was made
of synapses end up in the adult nervous
system and I just want you to think
about that because this may also be true
not just in muscle I know it's also true
in neurons and the peripheral nervous
system and it probably is true in a
number of parts of the central nervous
system as well that the ultimate wiring
diagram is not so much related to
canonical circuits but in some kind of
choice about which connections are
maintained and which ones are eliminated
and that allows what is difficult for a
child to do like to tell the difference
between a P and a Q becomes automatic in
an adult because there's no longer any
real computation going on you're now
wired if you will for a particular
perception or a particular motor output
whereas a child has trouble walking an
adult does it without thinking and
that's maybe because you're going from a
hyper complex nervous system that
doesn't know what it's designed to do
through experience becomes a simpler one
that is a biological
model based on bottom-up analysis of the
way wires change in the periphery I just
bring that up because I want you to
understand that for me at least there is
a way of thinking about models where you
start with biology and then generate a
model and then you say well what would
the equivalent of this be in the cortex
for example in this case it is
experience as you can show it's
experience by blocking activity or by
stimulating axons I was going to show
that when we did this wiring diagram
left and right side of the same animal
or this left muscle of animal after
animal every single one is unique every
single instantiation even the left and
right mirror symmetrical muscles have
different wiring diagrams the sets of
this chart that give the picture what
the sets of this choice like in the
picture like there are neurons
[Music]
I'll just show you
this is this is the real McCoy the nerve
and each color is a different axon
they're just distributed and that
pattern is different in every animal is
connected to a different set for every
motor neurone right that's right it's
one-to-one in the end at the beginning
it's many to one and one to many at the
end it's one axon goes to many but it's
the only axon left it's happened to
mammals it doesn't happen in fish yes it
would be it would be it would be but
that doesn't it doesn't help to blame
God she may have big ideas but I'm not
sure that's gonna help us make sense of
this one possibilities there aren't
enough genes another possibility is that
a brilliant idea happens some point in
evolution that you could make an animal
fit not by its genes per se but by
allowing its wiring diagram to be
modified by the experience of that
particular animal so that that's what I
think is the big key here because it
what's happened in mammals is instead of
having an identified neuron do something
as you find in insects or in worms you
have a whole bunch of neurons doing all
the same thing why do that it's because
you can then parse this out and make a
very complicated set of individual
wiring diagrams that you wouldn't be
able to do with genetics
you know you gave the example left and
right for all these crab numbers it's
it's true except I understated what's
actually here there's something called
the size principle where you recruit
axons in a fixed order from the largest
necessary from the smallest to the
largest these are not all the same
there's a biggest one there's a second
the biggest one and on every muscle that
are not a Gaussian distribution there's
a stepwise distribution of sizes and so
there is something being worked out here
and the ones that are small are causing
minor movements in the muscle and the
ones that are bigger only used when you
have a catastrophic requirement to in
this case pull the ear all the way back
very quickly and that is maintained but
the exact positions and wires are in
different places because the position
doesn't matter
it's anyway I wanted to get through that
very quickly and I failed okay so that's
what we did with light microscopy but
unfortunately at early developmental
stages and in the central nervous system
at any stage fluorescence techniques
like Brainbow don't have sufficient
resolving power to see each connection
of each axon if you label one axon you
can see it's wiring but if you want to
but you can't see the targets if you
want to see all the targets and you want
to see all the axons you can't use
fluorescence so we went to an electron
microscopy approach with much much much
better resolution to allow us to look at
volumes of tissue and so we had of an
automatic pipeline and you can start
with something like a window into the
mind of a rodent where do you look at
the activity patterns with dyes that
change the intensity of the light coming
back from individual cells fluorescence
while the animal is doing something like
looking at the world so this could be a
window into the visual system and you
cut out a piece of this brain you
profuse it and get rid of the blood and
then you go through a
a complicated staining procedure to put
heavy metals into every single membrane
and then we often take an x-ray to
provide us with a low resolution micro
CT image that shows us the location of
every neuron and that is useful because
it allows us to make sure that we can
align the light microscope microscope
activity to the electron microscopy we
then cut this up using a machine that
I'll explain in a second automatic tape
collecting ultra microtome and put this
brain on tape I'll show you how that's
done the tape is then put on a very
special holder and that holder allows us
to map the position of every piece of
brain section which is all along here
I'll explain that as well and then we
map all those positions and then send
that information into an electron
microscope a multi beam scanning
electron microscope the fastest electron
microscope I think ever built and I'll
explain what that is as well to allow us
to automatically take images of each of
these sections we then stitch and align
them this is computationally an
intensive process as the datasets are so
large and then ultimately the data is
segmented and rendered and Neera bead is
going to talk about these very
interesting technologies that he is
developing to do segmentation but I'm
gonna talk about Paul the pipeline up
there and give you some sense of the
kinds of things you get out of this and
we've already done this with a
laboratory of fish expert Florian Eggert
to do the myelinated pathways in a
larval zebrafish we've worked on human
brain organoids with the lab of Paro
Paola are a lot of and I'm just thinking
these as examples here Dennis Stacy
Rachael lung and John Dowling we worked
on a human phobia and with Arabi samuel
lab and gyro
here and near Shavit and masion in
Toronto we are participating in the
reconstruction of the wiring diagrams of
many different larval stages of this
worm that has such a small number of
nerve cells we're working on the
cerebellum these are all examples talk
about any of those today you may hear a
little bit about the worm this afternoon
and I hope and maybe some about a muscle
project that we're also involved in from
here so the key technology for this is
to take a three-dimensional piece of
brain and flatten it out into a series
of sections and we do this using an
automatic tape collecting ultra-micro
Toma little thing can Haworth and
Richard shallick built in the lab and as
a means of giving us a permanent picture
way of getting pictures of every little
part of the brain so you take a
three-dimensional brain and turning it
basically into a filmstrip and the way
this is done is that the brain is being
sliced by a diamond knife and the slices
are coming off in water I'll show you a
little movie of this place right here so
here's a diamond knife there's water in
this boat here the brain is being sliced
I insist on a knife it comes up in the
water and then you can see the sections
one after another being picked up by the
skipper and that's the approach and then
each of these sections is about 30
nanometers so about thousand of them
make up the thickness of a hair and we
can cut up to 10,000 sections a day any
sections are you know this section is
maybe a millimeter wide and two
millimeters long well we can do three by
two millimeter sections no problem and
then here Bobby Catherine is now at
Argonne in University of Chicago is
holding one of these wafers where we've
cut a strip of these tape to show you
what they look like once they're stained
with heavy metals and so he's moving
into the electron microscope now this is
the cerebral cortex that's these
hippocampus these big white things are
nerve cells this is a blood vessel these
white stripes you're seeing here are the
apical dendrites of those pyramidal
cells these black outlined objects are
myelinated axons that are in sheath and
then as we zoom up further and further
finally we get to a resolution where you
can see one of these cross-sections
filled with vesicles up against a
dendritic spine so this is a dendrite
there's a spine neck there's that spine
apparatus here's an axon filled with
synaptic vesicles and that's the synapse
between the two so that's good you can
take these tape and get images like this
we use a scanning electron microscope to
do this that's the good news the bad
news is that this image is right there
this is a millimeter by a little bit
more than a millimeter by millimeter one
point two by one point two millimeters
I remember that whole object when we
began we had to take a bunch of images
each of these little boxes is a separate
image we took on the electron microscope
of this one section 30 sections and we
were going pretty fast five million
pixels per second that's five times
faster than most kind of Fogle's take
pictures to get 30 times that took five
hours so five hours gives you this whole
image of one section which by the way is
only this big so it's not much if you
wanted to do not just that one section
but do that many sections in depth so
not only a millimeter by a millimeter
but a millimeter by a millimeter by a
millimeter you would have to do that if
you're doing 30 nanometers 33333 times
so you got to multiply five hours by
33333
17 years so nobody I've not been able to
find any graduate students interested in
this project wants to do this because
that's just insanely long so somehow we
have to go faster
we have to image the brain a lot faster
and for us the solution is this machine
which I'm up against that which allows
us to do the whole thing in six months
instead of 17 years it's not a
completely happy smile and there are
many reasons for this
the most obvious one you can't see until
I show you that I'm standing on a chair
with wheels
I'm just desperately holding on this
looks like a refrigerator but it's it's
like a refrigerator for Giants you know
I'm not very tall but still I'm standing
on a chair and I'm just barely reaching
the top of this about ten feet it's just
insanely tall it's also insanely
expensive and it was built for us by
this company and it's called the
multi-stemmed 505 and that 505 was there
simply to give me the confidence that
they knew what they were doing this is
really the multi 7.01
it's so there's a lot of issues here but
they they they're really magnificent
engineers and they built an amazing
machine it it is generating about 11
terabytes a day and it's probably the
fastest electron microscope ever built
and I'll explain how it works in a
second so you can take off that
beautiful cover and then see the
underlying engineering it's a sixty one
beam scanning electron microscope and
and the way it goes so fast is it
paralyzes the scanning process remember
I was show you that image with the 30
images taken in sequence this is a
machine that has 61 beams in it that all
work in parallel so that gives us a lot
more speed it's a very amazing complex
diagram and I won't go through too much
of the details other than to say there's
an electron source that goes through
something that looks a little bit like a
shower head with a bunch of little holes
in it and it generates that electron
beam in 261 separate beams that each
illuminate a separate region of the
specimen and each one is scanned
independently to make a little
rectangular box and then they generate
the electrons interaction with the data
the osmium generates secondary electrons
which are very low energy electrons that
come back out are pulled up and because
they're so low energy like a dichroic
mirror and a fluorescence microscope you
can pull them out of this high energy
beam the low energy electrons come out
here and each of those positions end up
in a separate place on a phosphor plate
and the phosphor plate if you which
generates light shows 61 beams arranged
in a hexagon that's and the one in the
middle is what makes it 61 beams then
there are 61 fiber optics that measure
the intensity of the light now coming
off of the phosphor screen and take that
those fiber optics go to 61 avalanche
photodiodes and then generate it back
into electricity why you go through
electricity to light and back to
electricity is an engineering design
issue but it works very nicely and so
you get images where each of these dots
are scanning a small region and you get
all this at once and this is what an
image looks like now so it's kind of
weird because it's sort of hexagonal and
we can generate a hundred and eight by a
hundred and eight microns in a much
smaller amount of time we call these m5s
microscopic field abuse with 61 images
taken at once and then to generate
something like a millimeter we
automatically just do this we take each
of these little green things as one of
those 61 beam hexagons and we tile this
all automatically and this is sped up
but this takes about five minutes to do
instead of five hours because we have 61
beams so recording 60 times faster
and then you carve out of each of the
sections the common area and make a
volume and maybe you get a sense here
that although this is jumping around
because of our targeting not being
precise the neurons aren't moving that's
these gray objects here and that means
that we have overcome the alignment
problem for very large datasets and I'm
going to show you I can if this still is
running so this is the largest data set
we've done to date this has 508 m fives
or about 36,000 tiles this is a project
that we're getting segmented through
Google with ver and Jane leading the
charge there and here I'm hooked into
their neuro glance er at their
headquarters or wherever this is I don't
know actually to have no idea where this
is now I'm just gonna this is online so
if in principle this works sixty-one
beams good good I mean each beam cost
money this only cost five million so
there's probably some economy of scale
here maybe a better thing would be to
have multiple machines like this because
then if one broke the other ones would
still be running I'm acutely aware of
this that that would be but yeah it's
you know it's new technology yeah so I
just give you a sense of the scale this
is a 300 gigabyte image so a terabyte
for every three sections
[Music]
you know it's it would take me probably
eight hours at this rate to get from one
end of the section to the other it just
goes on forever like this they'll give
you a sense of just what Big Data looks
like an image data here so this is a two
millimeters by two millimeters yep we do
image sources I'll show you that in a
second okay
so after that you carve out a data set
and I've shown you this zooming up just
by going automatically if I go back here
this will give you a sense of why
connectomics is so interesting if we you
look at the data now now we're looking
not just at one section but we're
playing that filmstrip going from
section to section it's been aligned by
a multi-core cluster these are nerve
cells and their nucleus that are coming
out of you and new ones coming into view
as we go into the data set all this
stuff moving around of course is not
alive it's it's moving around because
we're moving through a three-dimensional
volume and all these little objects are
axons and dendrites and these are nerve
cells and their nuclei and this goes on
for thousands of sections there's a
blood vessel up there I'm gonna go to
this resolution just so you can see
everything here so this is what connect
omics raw data looks like you have
processes you can follow them by eye
very very easily from section to section
occasionally they turn into synapses
here's a big cell and its nucleus
nucleolus that are is coming into view
those are mitochondria which are energy
organelles and to plasmic reticulum is
what this stuff is here the cell is
receding and then we're back into neuro
pill again we're wires are connected to
other cells and here's another neuron
appearing here it's just extraordinary
that this is what brains are made of I
can look at this all day I really can i
I like to look but I really love to look
at this stuff because it's so
interesting and the challenge of course
is to turn this into data and not just
pictures but this gives you a sense that
these techniques for alignment work and
then when you're done you end up with a
data set you know that could be a cube a
big cube of a brain tissue
and here it's on its edge so you can see
all six phases this is just a hundred by
a hundred by a hundred microns so it's
only two terabytes it's only three
thousand three hundred and thirty three
sections at this rate of cubic
millimeter would be two petabytes and
then from that you can reconstruct right
in this volume here is an inhibitory
yarn I will show you how we do this by
hand but now there are techniques that
do this automatically I hope that worked
very well
eventually they will do all of this this
is a neuron and inhibitory neuron with
its blue axon and myelin partially
myelinated processes here are two
pyramidal neurons one hundred by hundred
microns is so small it's hard you can't
get a whole pyramidal cell in there and
there's one there there's the apical
dendrite of another and here's some
inhibitory axons innervating a pyramidal
cell and I won't talk about the details
of this right now I just give you a
sense that this hundred by hundred by
hundred micron volume it which is a
million cubic microns is two terabytes
and it has about forty neurons and a
million synapses and what we are charged
by one of our grants to do now is a
cubic millimeter which will be a billion
cubic microns be that big two petabytes
forty thousand neurons everything's at
mill divided by a thousand it's not very
sophisticated kept doing here and a
billion synapses so we've already cut a
cubic millimeter I'll show you what that
looks like that's a lot of tape we
needed this much tape and we spliced it
all together and laid it out and to end
kinda and got a crowd to look at how big
it is it's a hundred and fifteen yards
and it's impressive at Harvard how
interested people are in connectomics
this happened also to be the
harvard-yale game and we weren't
actually there it's fake news but that's
how big that's how much tape it has all
those sections and here's all the
here's each of them this is just a
montage of 33,000 sections each section
looks like that and I could play a movie
it's awfully boring of all 33,000 of
them I'm playing it at 60 frames a
second so I can go fast but it's still
15 minutes or so to get through the
whole movie so I'm not going to bore you
with this but you can see that most of
the sections come off they look pretty
good this is the PIA this is the white
matter so this is the cortical thickness
of a rat there were 120 wafers we made
each one at 270 sections the sections
were a little bigger than a millimeter
by a millimeter they were 30 nanometers
in thickness
we only collected 986 microns because we
miscounted the number of sections we had
taken embarassingly but you you count to
33,000 and see if you you get it right
we did we had a lot to learn this is our
first try at this so we actually
sectioned 101.7 3 cubic millimeters and
most of the sections 98.3% were
satisfactory some had local defects and
103 were destroyed by the sectioning
that number sounds 0.3% not so bad for
us to do a cubic millimeter it means
that if these are random the probability
of two adjacent failures is one out of a
hundred and eleven thousand so it's not
likely to ruin our ability to do
reconstruction so here is the cubic
millimeter this is at low resolution not
at full resolution so we haven't done
that yet we're in the process of
starting this right now so what do you
do Daniel Berger made a program that's
just basically a digital coloring book
that allows us to take a stack of these
images find an object of interest and
color it in this is painstaking work
automatic segmentation as you'll hear
makes this all go much faster but this
does give you a sense of what you get
out of data like this so you can
generate a dendrite and its spines
you can generate the axon that
innervates those spines unambiguously
this is not just that they're near each
other but when you look in the e/m you
actually see as you'll see your synaptic
vesicles in the axon a budding the
dendritic spine so you know this is this
works and well what have we done with
this so here is an example of a piece of
cortex where we have rendered everything
in this area so everything is colored in
and there is these shapes appearing this
green shape it's very hard to infer the
three-dimensional shape of an object
from individual sections I don't know
anybody have an intuition about what
this shape is a cylinder very good yeah
it's for most people it's very hard to
see that this is a cylinder but that's a
cylinder around this apical dendrite and
this green cylinders around this apical
dendrite they each have spines and the
purpose of this paper was to simply ask
the question within the spine diameters
of these two dendrites what else is in
that same area so within the distance of
the spines away from the neuron is there
anything else there and obviously
there's a lot of other stuff there but
this show this will show you what is
actually there so here is the
reconstruction of those two dendrites we
did twice as much length of the red
dendrite as the green one there covered
with spines more spines than we expected
to see because we labeled everything we
couldn't miss any spines there was
nothing left unlabeled in there so we
got a high density of spines and this is
the spine that sticks out the farthest
you'll see it stick its head out a
little bit later so in addition to these
two dendrites there are lots of other
dendrites that are pushed in to this
area here here are all the dendrites in
this volume that's the red dendrite and
the green dendrite and all these other
pieces are pieces of dendrites of other
neurons that are within one spine
diameter
it's the longest spine right there of
this these two cells of course the
dendrites are gotta be innovated by
something so there have to be axons in
there too even though it doesn't look
like there's much room left there's
actually eight times more axons in this
volume than dendrites here are all the
axons it's kind of amazing that these
fit together so where there's a big hole
here you know there's a dendrite but
there's a lot of axons squeezed in there
but I'm still forgetting a cell type
somebody mentioned the astrocytes yes so
there's also got to be astrocytes in
there and there's all the astrocyte
processes which also seem to take up
most of the space so that's everything
sticking out like there and then we made
this movie just to show all those
objects
I don't know depressing is one word that
comes to mind when I look at this this
is not a big area we're looking at here
there's an extraordinary number of
things and we're just within the
dendritic spine distance of two
dendrites that are right next to each
other just amazing number of objects and
of course like to look so we identified
every one of those objects and they
could be divided roughly into axons glia
etc and dendrites and the axons could be
divided into myelinated axons inhibitory
axons and excitatory axons based on
structural differences the dendrites
there were spiny ones and smooth
dendrites those are the dendrites of
inhibitory neurons there were in
addition to astrocytes oligodendrocyte
processes that make the myelin that in
sheath axons and embarrassingly there
are a bunch of things that we don't know
what they are many of them we traced out
very long distances out of this little
volume and we still don't know what they
are they don't seem to make synapses or
receive synapses they just seem to be
growing so we don't know what they are a
couple of these we now know are
microglia and I I may have a chance I'll
show you
it's actually to astrocytes they tile
roughly like this but they interact
their two astrocytes and of course
they're not two whole astrocytes they're
just little pieces of two astrocytes
each astrocyte would be more like this
size so that seems impressive until you
realize that this is what we did these
are those two neurons we did nothing
basically nothing but if I make it big
it looks better but it is still really
really really small amount of work well
not small amount of work it was five
years 1,600 cubic microns at that rate
this is about three billions of a mouse
brain you know we can't if you do this
manually it would take a trillion years
to do a whole mouse spring so you can't
do it that way but in there there were
fourteen hundred and seven different
axons we know they're different based on
the branching patterns of axons and it's
in this paper if you're curious about
how we counted that they were different
not the same axon branching mostly
excited Tory axons there were lots of
dendrites in there 193 different neurons
were sending dendrites in there many
fewer dendrites and axons for
interesting reasons we think and 1,700
synapses in there so about a synapse
every cubic micron meaning that in a
cubic millimeter there will be about a
billion synapses cortex so what did we
learn I think there were a couple of
things that were surprising and one is
that if you think of the dendritic
spines let's say of the red dendrite
there are so many red dendritic spines
there it's an interesting question how
many other dendritic spines are within
its territory exactly in that same area
it turned out there were many more
spines of other neurons in the same area
so in the following movie all the spines
that are not from the red dendrite are
gray and all the red dendritic dendrite
spines are red you see that even right
within the diameter of the dendritic
spines of that red dendrite most of the
spines are coming from neurons they're
just pushed in there as well
and that is interesting because that
means that an axon running through here
has no greater chance of hitting the red
dendritic spines than any other spines
in fact it has a lower probability
nonetheless when we looked at an axon
that made a synapse on a red dendritic
spine and traced it
they often with much greater probability
than one would expect by chance
innervated other spines on the red
dendrite so here is the red dendrite and
here's Anna these are accents that are
finding multiple spines of the red
dendrite and not innervating the spines
of the other cells this kind of
selectivity is interesting because it
implies that this is not just a random
wiring diagram but rather axons are
selectively making lots of synapses on
some target cells and not on others
target cells in the same exact position
and if you make a lot of synapses that's
a very good way to have a powerful
synapse and a lot of theories about
learning are related to synapses getting
strong a good way to make a strong
synapse is to have the same axon
innervate a lot of spines of the same
target cell and that turned out not to
be unusual but common in our data we
found for example even though there's a
very short region a dendrite that had
five different spines all contacted by
the same axon the chance of this axon
just randomly finding five spines
associated with this dendrite and not
any of the other spines around it is
infinitesimally small yep so you say
that an axon contacts one particular
dendrite or not many of the others that
are around is this a pruning effect or
so might it sort of initially have
contact a lot of the others as well and
that is gone because it is to somehow to
notice whether it's one all right
I couldn't have said it better myself
this is the question we're after right
now we do the same thing in babies and
do a comparative connectomics do we find
that the convergence rate is different
what I didn't show in that work on
muscle I I just flipped through the
sides I didn't show it is that that
massive pruning is what's going on there
you start out with weak connections from
many neurons on each target cell and
then you end up with one very powerful
connection and the others are pruned
away maybe that's the same learning
paradigm going on I think initially it
should actually make contact and try
whether it's worth connecting exactly
there should be lots lots more inter
connectivity more convergence but weaker
connections that's what we're wondering
about and then sort of the state of the
art is that we can actually image every
synaptic vesical in every axon making a
synapse on the red dendrite and that is
what's shown here so these are only
axons that are synapsing on this
particular dendrite and not only are the
axons shown but each of the vesicles to
see whether some have more
neurotransmitter vesicles than others
and in fact there is a wide range of
synaptic vesicle densities so there's a
sort of the state of the art of what one
can do with Seri Liam but along yes
essentially the computing power of human
brain and there's some sort of like like
you can't create software the hardware
without understanding of brain you catch
on the brain well we've given up on
understanding honestly I think we're
we're all into a description yeah I
think you could describe it and you
could have perhaps machines that would
understand it in the sense that they
would you could simulate sort of brain
function in silico perhaps but I'm not
sure you would understand and I'm not
saying anything about you
I'm just saying fundamentally humans
brains are only this big and and you
have to take account here of thousands
and thousands maybe millions of things
happening simultaneously it's more like
a I'd say it is there ever a chance that
a human being will understand New York
City you're saying well that's
ridiculous
how can you understand it there's so
many things going on at the same time
this is even worse there's no I think
the word understanding is maybe the
wrong word I think our computers will
understand this I just don't think we
will sort of like if you had a computer
algorithm that's predicting the stock
market it understands the stock market
to do a better prediction than you can
do no matter how smart you are
so yeah computing power you just put
enough computers
yeah I mean I think there's a
possibility I think it's a different
kind of understanding than what
biologists like me want which is I sort
of tell you the answer and you say oh I
get it I don't think you're gonna get
this good well not for me
cuz I can't get it and and that was you
know what I wanted I've got a twenty
more minutes right okay this is a lethal
experiment it's a one point in time
experiment you could get an another
animal at another age but you can't you
can't do this except by cutting it up
and that usually means killing the
animal we have human data that is not
killed that thing I showed you with
neuro glance or that big data is human
data from a human that was not dead that
was it was removed from a patient who
had epilepsy but not it wasn't the
epileptic focus but it was just to get
in access so there are places we can get
data if that patient wanted we guess
could come back later and take out some
more brain I doubt any human being
wouldn't want that though so this is
really a one-time thing and that's its
big weakness as opposed to many of the
dynamic techniques we have but it does
give you a measure of everything that's
going on in the brain at that moment in
time and I think in adult brains with
most of what we're doing is using our
brains but you know we think that we're
still learning a lot you may be at your
age but at my age at least my children
tell me I'm not learning anything
because they don't want to hear anything
from me because they say I've heard
we've heard it all before dead they
don't ask questions they know the
answers because they know what I'll say
and I felt that way about my parents and
maybe you feel that about your parents
at some point to get to a point where
the brain is just pretty much working
pretty well
that's depressing so I just want to
point out one other quick issue that's
kind of interesting if you look at cells
that you haven't looked at before like
microglia this is a microglial cell in
rodent brain we found that the microglia
have processes that are attracted to
fill a podium that dendritic spines both
philip podium neurons this is not a sort
of textbook knowledge it's just it
emerges from looking at these microglia
that this microglia all these yellow
things are dendritic philip Odia of
neurons that are little processes stuck
out that touch the tips of microglia and
you know here's to philip Odia of two
different neurons that are touching a
microglia process so there are lots of
sort of bottom-up weird things that we
didn't know about before and here's one
that's really interesting here's a
neuron a pyramidal neuron the the
nucleus of the neuron is folded on one
side where most of the processes are
coming out and smooth on the other side
that's why we studied this cell but that
wasn't the thing that was really
interesting
go back here I think it was really
interesting as a capillary was running
right through the apical dendrite that's
just something like what but that is
true I mean this is not a theory this is
a fact and how that happened I have no
idea so in the remaining 15 minutes I
want to just show you a an attempt to
analyze a circuit now you're gonna hear
from murray i think a lot about thalamus
so i'm not going to talk much about this
except what what we saw in the jaws like
yeah
yes it's the only one we ever saw but I
don't know whether that makes it an
outlier or a very important thing that
happens once a million yeah I don't know
it is an outlier definitely an outlier
we thought the simplest place in the
brain to see a wiring diagram would be
in the thalamus where you go from retina
and there are retinal ganglion cell
types as I've already mentioned that
make different style synapses on the
lamb according cells the Wommack cells
that send their axons to the cortex and
I this is an oversimplification but in
general one thinks that there are kind
of pathways of information flowing from
the retina to the cortex related to
different types of retinal ganglion
cells they have different types of
synapses they innervate the Lama
cortical cells that have different
shapes in the mouse bipolar or stellate
and we wanted to do this do it quickly
and then go back in development and see
how pruning played a role in this that
was our goal this is what we found which
was something it looks more messy and
the first thing was that different kinds
of retinal cells as demonstrated by the
fact that they have consistently
different shaped types of synapses
innervated the same falafels cortical
cell so we had a kind of mixing of types
on the lamech oracle cells we also had
that the same type of retinal cell
individual retinal cells so it's the
same axon even would innervate different
type of cortical cell of flama cortical
cells like one axon would innervate both
bipolar and stellate cells we also found
that retinal cells from different kinds
that the same retinal axon if you trace
it out will form one kind of synapse on
some kind of thermo cortical cells and
consistently form another kind of
synapse on another kind of thalamic
cortical cell so this is saying that the
axons do different things on different
targets and this is say
the same axon innervates different
targets with the same kind of axon so
there's something everything is
different and complicated here and
finally we could not predict anything
about the connectivity in the mouse
basically by just looking at the shape
of the target cells it was not
predictive about who would innervate
these cells by just looking at their
shape and this is sort of a kaha lien
notion that if you see the shape of a
cell you can anticipate what type of
cell it is in this piece of retina in
this piece of thalamus at least we
couldn't do that
I just show you how this is done we took
a 100 terabyte data set and right in the
middle we found four Salama cortical
cells that were right next to each other
and we liked these cells because in
reconstructing them in the electron
micrograph microscope some of them were
bipolar and some of them were stellate
so we said okay we've got several types
they're right next to each other and
then we're going to reconstruct them and
the way we did this just show you how
connectomics analysis goes so we take
one of those cells reconstruct its
dendrites and then find all the synapses
from the retina onto these dendrites by
looking for synapses that have light
mitochondria where we can trace the
axons out into the optic nerve coming in
to the the optic nerve the optic tract
no optic tract anyway we find all those
axons that make those synapses onto
these dendrites then trace those axons
back and find all the other synapses
they make in the thalamus and then for
each of those axons we trace those
synapses forward to find all the other
thigh lamb according cells innovated by
these same axons and in this way we get
the cohort of thalamic cortical cells
that share innervation with that cell in
white and we did that for each of those
four cells that were right next to each
other so that was the that's basically
the process you'd make it as the seed
cell and reconstruct back and then
reconstruct forward
this the quartic Oh Google we're doing
that right now no these are proximal
dendrites the distal tips are not
innovated so you end up if you just draw
this out with big mess so you have to do
something even as biologists we know you
can't just look at this and make any
sense out of it so we did a network and
and this is just a spring force Network
some of you probably understand that
works like this it's not a spatial
Network
it just says for each of the seed cells
these big circles what are all the
phenomenal axons that innervate these
cells those are these little triangles
and then what are all the other
Salameh cortical cells that share
innervation from those same triangles so
all these red circles are thalamic
cortical cells that share input with
this seed cell and these are phenomenal
cortical cells that share retinal input
with this seed so and so on and you can
see the fact that this is all
interconnected is that there isn't
absolutely ambiguously unambiguous
pathways for each of these cells they
are all interconnected and this is
dominated unfortunately by the seed
cells so we have to sort of get the seed
cells out of the spring force model the
springs are strongest when there are a
lot of synapses shared and weakest when
there are very few synapses shared and
since all the seed cells we got all the
synapses there's a lot on there so we
get we just don't give the springs any
force for the seed cells so they're out
here and then we're left with a network
that is more sort of objective and again
it's still highly interconnected and -
I'm making a very long story very short
here but to make sense out of this we
said maybe
the weakest connections are least
important maybe there is some
organization but let's not throw let's
not focus on these weak connections what
about the strong connection so one way
to do that is to take this spring force
model seed cells are out and then prune
away the weakest connections to break
this into smaller cohorts and I'm doing
that process for you now and I'm gonna
stop it arbitrarily at this point and
I'm just putting arbitrary colors around
these groups that all are related to the
Lama cortical cells that share input
with the first seed cell I showed you
these are the green ones that first
white cell was this cell and so this is
a bunch of thalamic cortical cells that
are still tightly interconnected but
somehow separated from these thalamic
cortical cells and these and these and
these and each have a different set of
retinal ganglion cells that they're
associated with so this single seed cell
seems to be a bunch of smaller groups
even though everything is very large and
interconnected in space for some reason
that seed cell has a set of flama
cortical cells and retinal ganglion
cells that are closely associated with
each other and separable from these
other sets and the reason I colored
these is to show you that if you look at
where these synapses are located on the
seed cell they're each located in a
different region of the seed so even
though these axons are growing
everywhere the five groups of retinal
ganglion cells associated with the green
seed sell each innervate a different
region of the seed cell dendritic Arbor
implying that there's some kind of inter
dendritic as opposed to neuron doctrine
organization of networks in the thymus
it's a very weird thing I mean I
wouldn't have expected this but this
region of this dendritic tree is
associated with all these the
a cortical cells these retinal ganglion
cell axons innervate this and also
innervate all these circles here and
that's distinct from the ones that are
associated with this part of the
dendritic tree what is this
that's dendritic organization is not at
the level of neurons now it's at a
smaller level so we ask the question how
is it possible that all the axons that
innervate this region also let's say
innervate this cell a different Flamel
cortical cell that shares exactly the
same axons as this region here all these
axons innervate this region and also
innervate that cell so we reconstructed
with connectomics you can reconstruct
anything so we reconstructed and
discovered that the axons that were on
that dendrite are fasciculation as a
group and they hop from one dendrite to
another dendrite of another Salama
cortical cell neuron now this kind of
dendritic hopping of a whole bunch of
axons has not been seen before because
you can't see it with any other
technique if you label all the axons
there's there's axons everywhere if you
label one axon sure you'll see an axon
jump from one dendrite to another but
you won't make much of it but if you
label all the axons on one dendrite and
you find that all of them on mas go over
to another dendrite you can only do that
with connectomics and not only is the
excitatory input doing that but the
inhibitory there's an inhibitory axon
that is also hopping from one to the
other yes I do not know I'm assuming
that these cells have a receptive field
property related to the topography the
retinotopic in the thalamus so I'm
assuming they're from the same part and
I'm assuming that they may be different
functions that are dendritic ly isolated
to different places and because there's
inhibition you could turn on and turn
off a channel onto this cell with the
inhibition perhaps
yes in this case we're only looking at
the number of synapses which turns out
both in the cortex and and the thalamus
to be a dynamic interesting metric it's
may be that there are changes in the
efficacy of single synapses but there's
no doubt that there is some kind of
strength associated with how many
synapses you make and that's not
surprising but that clearly is taking
advantage so I don't I mean I can
imagine I mean many of these axons make
so many synapses they may drive the cell
to threshold from the thalamus from the
retina some of them make one synapse and
then they make it second and a third and
a fourth to glom on to these proximal
dendrites they're close to the cell body
so they're probably pretty powerful
there's no path there I mean this is the
whole thalamus is like this it's just
filled with these fascicle you see it in
the cortex bunch of axons are running
together you know you just think oh
they're running next to each other but
in the thalamus at least many of them
are not only running together but they
are innervating the same target cells
and the because the inhibition I'm just
going to end with this because the
inhibition is doing that as well Josh
and I began looking at these local
inhibitory interneurons which are
gigantic cells here's one of them and
what Josh did was find every single
synapse made onto and out and coming off
of this local inhibitory neuron and this
is a picture that doesn't do justice to
what the data is here but this neuron
basically has by functional axon
dendritic processes everywhere Mary
Sherman I think is I think you've said
this for a long time and this is
definitely the case for cell like this
every single process is
both receiving inhibitory synapses from
the retina 713 synapses and sorry the
green ones are the retinal synapses on
and at every red place is a synapse the
cell is making so the cell is making and
receiving synapses on virtually all of
its processes it doesn't seem like a
cell that's collecting information and
sending out an axon and that's
demonstrated by the fact that when you
look at how they're related to the
phenomenal cortical cells any dendrite
that gets it within any localization to
this cell gets innervated by this
inhibitory neuron it's all local
interactions and it participates in that
entire network I showed you about before
it had no selectivity there and in
addition it had a thousands of other
neurons that it innervated and to make
matters even worse every synaptic motif
I know about with inhibition direct
inhibition feed reciprocal inhibition
feed-forward inhibition feed-forward
disinhibition some weird kind of thing I
don't even know what to call this this
cell does it all and this is a you know
a challenge I think going forward so I
just end with this one last point there
is a great complexity problem coming at
us I keep saying understanding is a
problem and I'll tell you this is so
rare for me to feel that the paradigm is
shifting under my feet and I'm not
really sure what to do about it when I
was young we had lots of good theories a
lot of understanding or pseudo
understanding this it felt like
understanding and the only thing that
never got in the way was data we didn't
have any information and now what's
happening as you can imagine is the
information is getting very heavy and
the biggest casualty of this big data
may be these big ideas and this is the
challenge I think for the future and for
computer scientists is how does somehow
leverage this information for something
I don't know whether it will be the word
understanding whether it'll be models
that are predictive that no one
understands but at least are in silico
model
the way the brain works I'm not sure
what it is but this is the challenge
going forward and it's your problem not
mine thank you very much you've got this
five million dollar machine that slices
things up and takes it but don't you
have enough data to like if you didn't
cut another brain couldn't you do
analysis for a very very long the right
we're going absolutely but I think the
hope is to take this out of the hands of
people like me to use automatic
segmentation you'll hear about that
later today and then do all this
analysis at a much bigger scale to
really see what's there rather than what
humans can pick out in these trivially
small data sets I see that right I don't
like it but it's the truth
yeah it's a good point so you've shown
examples where you serve by these
techniques figure sort of new patterns
of connectivity these kinds of things so
that's one kind of insight that you can
get from this data from the first part
of your talk I somehow imagined you
would ideally like to sort of scan a
whole brain and give the data to
somebody so what would you have hope to
learn from such a whole brain thing I
mean I relate to the comment on
networks but we know everything but
still it's not of much use to now go
through the sinuses of this network and
and try to learn how it is doing things
still we have an understanding how a
convolutional Network works but not on
the level of the detail connectivity
I mean I'm of the opinion that more
information is better than less even
though in my instinct here is that the
biggest impediment to understanding is
actually getting more information the
more information we have the harder not
the easier it's people say to me no yeah
you're right we don't understand today
but in 50 years we'll understand say no
it's gonna be even worse it's not
getting better there's again more and
more and more and more and more it's not
unless you're hoping that somehow out of
all this will crystallize some simple
idea it's very unlikely because biology
is was not designed to be understood it
was just designed to work and and this
is a real problem it's very different
with understanding things humans make
that were based on ideas this isn't
based on ideas it's based on accidents
of evolution so what do we do I mean
it's like what is the Hubble telescopes
value it looks out in space and sees all
these weird things and we try to build
theories based on what it sees you could
say well I'm not sure I'm gonna be able
to make a theory based on all that so it
should we should stop looking it's I
think it's sort of antithetical to the
human notion of exploration you explore
and you see things you didn't see before
and then you have to deal with it and
maybe dealing with this kind of data is
different from dealing with other kinds
of data I don't know that's my view
about this Watson Crick moment here
yeah I mean remember the Watson and
Crick moment was going down that you
that was going down it was reducing this
is going up and and when you go up in
genomics is a good example you end up
with a massive amount of very
interesting genomic data for example in
genomics and it's not that people say
someday we'll understand it it's it's a
little posed question to say can I
understand the genome you can understand
every little bit of it and and it's a
bunch of little special things on 20,000
genes that work in time and space to
generate all the phenotypes in an animal
through biochemistry and
three-dimensional structures there's
nothing general there's just data and
and genomics is a field that don't is no
longer trying to come up with a Watson
and Crick moment it's trying to leverage
that information to get insight into
what kinds of genes are important for
disease and evo-devo questions we're
going up branches that we've already we
have reductive knowledge to build
something out of imeem you may not
remember but I put a big question mark
from from the law of dynamic
polarization that qahal had to connect
omics I would say when we see dendrites
being independent entities when we see
glial cells associated in art ways when
we see so much connectivity that is not
predicted by kaha then in fact you are
you're in a world where you're both
learning new things and building a data
set and I don't know which of those two
is more important or whether both will
happen but that happen in genomics as
well imprinting which is fundamental was
not part of the way down it was on the
way back up and it it is changing the
way a lot of people think about
phenotype
between your technique and clarity so
clarity no no I mean clarity and all the
other clearing techniques and clarity is
a clearing technique of which there are
many a guy named Doug Richardson and I
wrote a review and sell of all the
imaging clearing techniques they're all
for optical imaging so they're limited
by diffraction and diffraction is
limited by the numerical aperture of the
lens so you're talking about lateral
resolutions of a micron or half a micron
at best and Zee resolution of
three-quarters of micron or worse so
compared to these nanometer things you
can't see any of this
is a seed of a rule for viral and
there's many different studies both
connect Tomac and Thomas or Chris Norton
we do this plenty more where the seeds
of the rules of wiring are emerging and
if you have the rules of wiring and you
can simulate wire
to restructure we're just very first
steps of this long program but you know
it's employment you know an optimistic
yeah I would agree with that I guess the
way we put it is let's do as much brain
as we need to do until it gets boring
that is that we're not going to see
anything we haven't seen before I mean
the wiring may differ but not it only in
ways that our models would predict it
would differ that we're not seeing any
new phenomena and is a cubic millimeter
enough or do you have to do a whole
mouse brain or do you have to do a brain
of many different species to see that
wide group of ideas but maybe a very
small amount of brain is enough and that
one doesn't have to do a whole brain and
that and then because everything else is
predictable based on what you've already
seen we are certainly not there yet I
mean maybe there's a thousand more rules
to see I think we'd beat Arden
extraordinarily lucky it was the very
first time we look at a thumb is one
rule that was missing it's very unlikely
very interesting that you mentioned
genomics in context
[Music]
I was wondering if it's even scarier
Thunder I mean my view is that there are
many single-celled organisms that have
behaviors as sophisticated as those that
have central nervous systems protozoa if
you watch them behave in their natural
environment their single cells they
don't have a nervous system they have a
massively complicated behavioral
repertoire they have sex they avoid
things they're attracted to things they
do all sorts of things and they do it
all by biochemistry there's no wires no
nothing so from that perspective there
is a rich mysterious way in which
molecules generate behavior and and if
that were sufficient we would just be
one gigantic cell but because of
diffusion limitations we have to funnel
those signals into long little pathways
and so our dendrites are in a sense
surrogates for molecular pathways
perhaps that would be my way
one question is um yeah it seems pretty
kind of challenging
what would you describe to us to
understand this and I wonder if we
actually take together I mean so that
rather than just looking at the
structure we really try to to kind of
gather data sites where we have not only
the structure but maybe also because I
mean somehow this makes you know if you
just look at the structure makes the
assumption about every neuron does its
own thing and has to if you have to
understand the communication with all
these other cells and it's extremely
complicated but maybe if we do both
things together there might be actually
some some paths serviced so this body
and not somehow I think a lot of people
think that is true
my view is that most of the activity
data is sampled over matters of ours
which is almost certainly a very very
very small subset of the behavioral
repertoire at the activity level of the
area you're looking at so if you
overemphasize what you're seeing there
99.9% of the synapses are just
irrelevant and and so I'm not sure
that's the right answer either it
couldn't hurt it's more information it's
something to look at but it's maybe not
sufficient I think of the wiring diagram
as having the entire repertoire of what
could happen is right before you and it
must constrain your models some way to
know what that repertoire is but yeah
this complexity plants yeah that's right
well you know a worm's genome is about
the size of our genome and they only
have 300 neurons so I I think with
humans what's going on is you have a
very very large brain with a duplication
of cells huge duplications every cell
type has reiterated millions and
millions of times and then you're doing
something with those cells to parse out
the war
information into a form that you can use
it for behavior information has to be in
the genome accepted but not learning but
not learning I think this is a red
herring in my view I think it's a red
herring I think for the retina it's not
a red herring because you're trying to
make a filter that doesn't require
learning in order to extract information
from the world but the ability to read
that's not that's not from your genes
it's from your experience and the
language you speak the tennis game you
play or whatever you know that's all in
your in your learning and that's what
most of your brain is made up of if you
think about what you do most of the day
oh yeah I don't think you'd play tennis
all day but you know you are using your
brain for things related to thinking
with a language which you didn't have
when you were born the reading happening
and so which ones do not have yeah it's
saying that the algorithm for learning
is not in plants they don't need to
learn in order to survive although they
better they may have to learn how to
read soon because we are doing our best
I think we probably
[Music]